you get stay that back
corner work on the
circles so you have two are going to go
in the back and then this one on inside
I'm turning inside the circle I just
made so I'm in the back
outside and then the
inside front
boom
boom back out side
inside never here in
front and then straight line
turning okay let's
try so as a reference point be aware
where my spine is on that spiral and
where his spine is on that spiral so
he's going outside I've come to the
back behind him so we're looking the
same way on this one that's what I got
to get to as he comes around I can't
wait for him to now face
me so as he comes around I moved inside
the that so he's looking that way I'm
looking that way and he comes around and
I'm already
gone
same way
gone it's very calm here or you go like
that and now you're looking the same way
incorrect
okay try it again all right so in your
art you're trying to transcend form
don't get stuck on form so Tenon in
Japanese just means changes in the sense
change the relationship between Naga and
UK it does not mean uh 180° turn you
just start it's just introduced with
that 180° turn so if you pay attention
if I do 180° turn we're not
actually looking in the same direction
so I was supposed to be over here so pay
attention to my
footwork it's more than
180°
can you see that that way I stay in the
back so instead follow principles that's
determines what you're doing instead
follow principles that determines what
you're
doing not that form that was introduced
to you as a beginner okay try
to even if you get away with just being
in the hand you don't okay you you don't
feel me just in in your hand you see
right the whole time I'm not just in
your hand I'm I'm moving the
center can you feel
that I'm not out here on the
hand you see that
so
Center Center CER I'm exaggerate so you
can
feel Center
Center got it okay let's
go make sure there's a a drop you feel
that drop you know what I
mean that's what I was exaggerating
earlier on you that you can feel the
drop do you see I don't want you to go
that L cuz I want you to keep moving
baby there's a pressure on your drop on
your Ascender one boom
[Music]
here and you just keep it
going
[Music]
don't hit your head
okay don't hit your face
okay let's go pay attention so just as
as he's coming around and I didn't wait
for him here understanding that he's
going to keep coming
around I have to keep that understanding
that he's going to keep coming
around you see
that if I cut on my
initial entry angle he keeps coming
around I'm cutting
backwards to
keep align with the
spiral
okay you're trying to hit his face on
the street but UK doesn't do that okay
next Drew I'm going to do the same thing
but I'm going to clear his arms okay
clear his
arms
but here I
use now I'm the one working
it Joon you're in the elbow now clear
[Music]
it
you if if you can you'll find that
you'll find the I adhesion on the
palm at the on the lower
wrist boom right here right there
if you can grab the
G
clear okay
try in the b
boom I'm passing the
adhesion inh adhesion in the wrist
adhesion in the Palm right palm left
palm right palm
left P
[Music]
Miss if you wanted to do what I
did
okay you going switch Palms every time
okay TR if not you can't do it I want
you to just graub it okay you go go back
to the grip now and we're going to start
working on the bottom element of a topsy
tury effect if you just have the top top
element the the rukmi is your face goes
down not you you roll okay so we're
going to start working on the bottom
element so go back a step hold and I'm
not going to
clear I'm I'm good at Clear just enough
that he still comes around but I'm in
the way when he finally comes around I'm
going to change my height right here
boom this
way
well I'm not in the way until comes
around this barely clip
Up
oh turn it one way turn it the other way
boom
[Music]
okay if your UK camp take you KY then I
do want you to miss them okay just right
outside you won't clip their legs all
right let's try pay
attention um you can't guess you're like
doing eoic mind intellect oh that was
too far that's too close and then I'll
go X Factor too close or X Factor closer
and you're just bouncing back and forth
in the M from incorrect incorrect on one
side incorrect on the incorrect on the
other side if you're reverse engineer
and you you see that he has centrifugal
energy if I have I or J ding here so I'm
not I'm neither Yin nor
y a Oneness a communion establishes and
I move at a r
and at a range and a degree of rotation
so that I I keep that feeling and not
that feeling or that feeling got it it's
just neutral what I call neutral
y so I come out and that's telling me
where to move that sensation is telling
me where to move that
sensation so if I go positive Young
you'll start to
slip as opposed to go back as he's
coming in I can use that energy to S you
understand it doesn't matter if he's
grabbing on me I shouldn't feel his grip
pulling on me and in the case of him
he's bigger than me and if I pull on his
fingers it hurts on my
shoulder it's not going to happen I got
to pee in the neutral y the iy position
the J G I'm not retreating I'm not
pushing I'm not pulling get it you feel
what your hand is doing to tell you
where to go so I shouldn't feel
anything you I shouldn't feel my
strength nor my
weakness That's The Sweet Spot in modern
turn sweet
spot my hand does doesn't require
anything to fall down
with second
point when you
drop you always drop on the balls of
your feet never
here balls are your feet so you can
stand
up
so you can stand
up follows your feet let's start your
now from where you left off okay so
let's go back to the the II tyo one
two there's North you tell me did I
Advance
North or did I go in another
Direction what yes or no did I go north
yeah
yes so you're coming around and you you
actually enter you go
forward it's just that he's coming
around me might not look like I went
forward but I do go
forward so when you do this
drill you're not going to go backwards
stay in place and let him come
over your skill of your UK is going to
decide how much you enter cuz I don't
want anyone's legs
broken but I am going in okay okay so
I'll demonstrate that point now I'm
going to go
[Music]
here so I took out the top element of
the top
turke
boom and I'm going to go
in
don't go too much or
what if you ask too much of it what's
going to happen you're going to feel
your strength you're going to feel your
strength okay you just need a little
clip that's all you need don't sacrifice
your posture or anything for that little
clip I'm not actually ahead I'm not in
front of him because he's coming around
as I cut through the middle of the SP so
I just want a little clip okay so I'm
going to do the technique and you're
going to try to see or look for that
little clip you obviously been feeling
it okay so I'm coming
around
see yeah in fact I I noticed that I'm
turning one more spiral inside his
spiral okay that's how much Ed me is
there again let the skill of your UK
decide so you have to speak up UK I
can't take that Uki and keep my knees
safe okay go okay now we'll go back to
the other the other one where I'm going
this way Mo HP
in again if you if you don't have the
adion uh you go ahead and just grab
him I find there's no need to come back
down to the wrist on this version but if
you
do
make sure that's the last part you stick
[Music]
on
okay let's go so this throw is open
let's say from the
clinch okay so
um I can you can see it right here on
this arm just start your spiral right
who then you have it right here on this
arm over here you're going to go in
same clinch if you want okay if you want
to work this arm it's over here home
in and
around your spirals can be smaller now I
don't care dude just grab me there um
you can start the spiral this way if you
want with Ido Tenon you can go this way
doesn't
[Music]
matter he drives is when you do
it so when you draws that's your ten con
and then you comeing
in so the UK dries both
hot
okay either way you start the rotation
one way then you cut inside going under
the arm clip the bottom legs okay here
we go all right so this is not katuma
okay so right here like this I'm not
going here like this putting them on my
shoulder
ERS and then throw it here this is a c
nugget okay if you try for the C nugget
first you're going to make your katuma
more viable so at first I'm trying to
clip you didn't quite get the topy Turvy
effect then your katuma is going to be
more viable so don't go for the shoulder
Str okay right here I go one way when it
comes back I
C
you see I'm not entering very deeply and
I keep you moving over
me and you go back to the
rules that I shouldn't feel my strength
boom
think of it more as a fitting drill he's
pushing I shouldn't feel my leg
strength he pushes I turn comes back
around everything's very live but
everything's very stuck you see
everything's very
stuck you see it's very
sticky you go bur St oh
clip okay don't feel